cada día de partido es como un
peregrinaje en el barrio copenhague de
Berlín desde hace unos meses los hinchas
del club de fútbol local el FC Unión
Berlín se sientan en las nubes cuando
van al estadio contra todo pronóstico su
equipo está en el top cinco de la
Bundesliga
en este momento aprovechamos cada
partido al máximo es de no creer
lo que estamos viviendo en este momento
es como un sueño de unos años para acá
los resultados del equipo son
impresionantes
más cuando el equipo no la ha tenido
fácil el club fue fundado por obreros
metalúrgicos en la ex República
democrática alemana y desde la
reunificación ha enfrentado un sinnúmero
de dificultades pero luego llegó ese 27
de mayo de 2019 cuando ascendió a
primera división un momento histórico
para los hinchas
booker ha escrito seis libros sobre su
equipo así resume la filosofía de
Quienes son conocidos Como los hombres
de hierro
vivimos juntos ganamos juntos y perdemos
Juntos por eso se prohíbe chiflar a los
jugadores del equipo pelearse con un
jugador o irse del estadio antes del
pitazo final hay que regresar a casa sin
voz de tanto gritar
los hinchas son ese jugador número 12
que marca la diferencia para este Club
en 2018 fueron precisamente ellos
quienes repararon el estadio donando
140.000 horas de trabajo voluntario y el
equipo se mantiene fiel a su origen
obrero Aquí no hay estrellas sino
jugadores aguerridos respaldados por sus
seguidores
no hacemos diferencia entre el equipo
empleados y los hinchas somos una
familia cada uno contribuye al éxito que
estamos viviendo en este momento Y eso
es seguramente lo que hace que nuestro
Club sea tan particular
una familia que no deja de crecer el
Unión tiene 50.000 hinchas registrados
según el sitio web del club para un
estadio de 22.000 plazas